[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport ein
schwimmender familie und wir haben unter
anderem diese themen für sie
will öl-embargo gegen russland eine
wichtige einnahmequelle für putin könnte
schon bald weitgehend versiegen
bus und bahn zum schnäppchenpreis wegen
des neuen euro tickets für alle
befürchten verkehrsbetriebe und länder
hohe verluste
und sieg im hexenkessel der fc liverpool
sieht in villarreal ins finale der
champions league ein
[Musik]
wir wollen dass die ukraine diesem krieg
gewinnt sagt eu-kommissionspräsident in
von der leyen deswegen schlägt die
kommission jetzt dieses sechste
sanktionspaket gegen russland vor ein
teil ist der importstopp von russischem
öl der soll in sechs monaten gelten mit
sonderregeln für ungarn und die slowakei
offen ist wie sehr das embargo russland
tatsächlich schwächen würde und ob die
mitgliedsstaaten zustimmen florian
neumann berichtet noch bis kurz vor
ihrem auftritt hatten sie gerungen wie
die kommission kritische eu
mitgliedsstaaten überzeugt von einer
sanktion die europa auch selbst schadet
ein embargo auf russisches öl
machen wir uns nichts vor das wird nicht
einfach einige mitgliedstaaten hängen
erheblich von russischem öl ab aber wir
müssen es einfach tun
noch importiert europa russisches öl im
wert von 450 millionen euro pro tag und
finanziert damit auch putins kriegskasse
nach dem vorschlag der kommission aber
nicht mehr lange in sechs monaten will
man kein rohöl mehr importieren in acht
monaten keine ölprodukte eine
verlängerung soll es geben für ungarn
und die slowakei
die beiden länder fast vollständig von
russischem öl abhängig hätten bis ende
2023 zeit fielen im europaparlament
dauert das zu lange
das feld weit hinter dem zurück was
dieses parlament schon vor einem monat
gefordert hat nämlich ein komplettes
embargo auf gas und eine neue andere
fürchten drastisch steigende
energiepreise auch bei uns deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt ein europaweiter
energiepreis deckel damit energie armut
effektiv bekämpft werden kann schärfere
sanktionen auch im finanzbereich jetzt
soll auch die größte russische bank
sberbank vom zahlungssystem
ausgeschlossen werden dass die
sanktionen zu einem schnellen kriegsende
führen aber glaubt kaum jemand die
botschaft an putin war von anfang an
sehr klar wenn du eine invasion und
einen krieg in der ukraine auslöst wirst
du ein ganz ganz hohen preis zahlen und
schritt für schritt mit den sanktionen
setzen wir das auch durch noch müssen
alle eu mitgliedstaaten den sanktionen
zustimmen ungarn hat schon vorbehalte
angemeldet
ungarn hat schon vorbehalte florian in
straßburg obwohl die eu dem land schon
entgegenkommt bröckelt da die einigkeit
der europäischen union
das wird zumindest schwieriger diese
union zusammenzuhalten denn jetzt so
sagte es ein diplomat kommen eben die
sanktionen die europa auch selbst
wirtschaftlich schaden und zwar mit
durchaus massiv aber trotzdem gibt man
sich hier bei der kommission doch sehr
zuversichtlich dass diese dieses öl
embargo bis ende der woche auch
beschlossen sein wird man ist den beiden
staaten ungarn und der slowakei ja
massiv entgegen gekommen während alle
anderen eu staaten bis ende dass dieses
jahres eben auf russisches öl verzichten
sollen gibt man beiden staaten ein
weiteres jahr zeit dass beide jetzt noch
mehr verlangen dass dort nie viele als
teil des üblichen brüsseler machtspiels
an dass sie eben einfach den preis
hochtreiben in 12 nachtsitzungen dann
noch mehr ergattern wollen eine längere
übergangsfrist etwa am ende wird europa
dieser sanktionen eben mit zwei
geschwindigkeiten vorangehen erstmals
also die einigkeit die bröckelt ein
wenig aber man ist bereit diesen preis
zu zahlen um eben überhaupt
voranzukommen bei dieser sanktionen
dankeschön nach straßburg florian
neumann mal dass
die folgen dieser sanktionen werden alle
zu spüren bekommen die preise für öl
gingen heute direkt nach oben die an den
tankstellen werden wohl folgen nach
einschätzung von wirtschaftsminister
habeck ist die übergangs das zwar lang
genug um alternativen zu russischen öl
zu finden dennoch könnte es in
ostdeutschland regional stoppen sagte er
bei der regierungsklausur in meseberg
heike slansky hat mehr
tag zwei des arbeitstreffens der
koalition auf schloss meseberg
zurückgezogen in entspannter atmosphäre
thematisch jedoch überschattet vom krieg
in der ukraine der deutschland und die
welt verändert hat klar ist auch dass
aus dieser veränderung feucht dass putin
sich vollständig verrechnet hat mit
seinem brutalen anderes krieg gegen die
ukraine denn was er bekommt ist eine
stärkere nato ist die stärkere
organisation von sicherheit auch an den
östlichen staaten des nato gebietes was
er bekommen hat ist eine einige
europäische union die auswirkungen des
krieges steigende energiepreise eine
enorm hohe inflation das geplante öl
embargo wird zu weiteren belastungen
führen die regierung will betroffenen
standorten wie schwedt und leuna helfen
die übergangsfrist ist so ausreichend
lang dass wir alle vorkehrungen treffen
können um alternativen für russisches öl
in deutschland zu schaffen
vorkehrungen treffen heißt nicht dass
sie sich gleich realisieren ein zügiger
bauch von flüssiggasterminals soll auch
die abhängigkeit von russischem gas
reduzieren ebenfalls der schnellere
ausbau von erneuerbaren außerdem werden
weitere sanktionen geprüft zum beispiel
ob er gesetz sanktionierte ihr vermögen
offenlegen müssen das wäre ein ganz
neues instrument um die durchsetzung
bestehender sanktionen gegen natürliche
personen gegen juristische personen um
das schlagkräftiger zu machen den druck
auf putin erhöhen gleichzeitig die
ukraine weiter unterstützen und
geflüchtete schneller integrieren themen
auf der kabinettsklausur in unsicheren
zeiten
zum geschehen in der ukraine auch am 70
kriegstag gab es wieder heftige kämpfe
entlang der front zugleich versuchten
helfer weitere zivilisten aus mario pohl
auch aus dem umkämpften stahlwerk dort
nachsah borussia zu bringen russland
griff unterdessen mehrere strategisch
wichtige bahn stationen an eine neue
lemberg das ziel den nachschub an
westlichen waffen abschneiden lena
sünder bruch
feuerwehrleute kämpfen in der nacht
darum die flammen in einem kraftwerk in
lemberg unter kontrolle zu bringen die
stadt nahe der polnischen grenze war
bislang weitgehend verschont geblieben
nun aber versucht russland durch
gezielte luftangriffe mehr denn je die
infrastruktur hier und im ganzen land zu
lähmen offenbar um westliche
waffentransporte zu stoppen ich möchte
darauf hinweisen dass wir jeden nato
transport der mit waffen und nachschub
für die ukrainischen streitkräfte ins
land kommt als legitimes militärisches
ziel betrachten
vom westen in den osten der ukraine nach
mariupol dort bereitet man sich auf eine
weitere evakuierung vor
natürlich werden wir weiterhin alles tun
um alle unsere leute aus mariupol und im
stahlwerk herauszuholen derzeit halten
sich die russischen truppen nicht an die
vereinbarungen sie setzen ihre massiven
angriffe auf das stahlwerk fort
russland dementiert das obwohl us
amerikanische satellitenbilder neue
rauchwolken über dem stahlwerk zeigen
helfer der vereinten nationen kümmern
sich um die mehr als 150 menschen die
gestern von dort in sicherheit gebracht
werden können nach mehr als zwei monaten
im bunker sind sie zurück im tageslicht
und es gibt die vermutlich erste warme
mahlzeit seit langem
es war schrecklich von morgens bis
abends wurden wir bombardiert artillerie
raketen luftangriffe die kinder konnten
nicht schlafen haben geweint sie hatten
angst und wir auch
in mariupol harren noch rund 100.000
zivilisten aus sergej und ludmilla sind
zwei davon sie versuchen in den trümmern
ihres hauses zu überleben
meistens die iren die russen hochhäuser
und hier haben sie genau den zweiten
stock getroffen da lebte eine frau jetzt
ist sie dort begraben
die russen hätten ihnen erlaubt in den
süden russlands umzusiedeln erzählt
ludmilla doch das hätten sie abgelehnt
und so lebt das ehepaar wie viele weiter
inmitten der bombardements
katrin eigendorf in kiew gibt es im
moment überhaupt noch verhandlungen
zwischen den kriegsparteien
also interessanterweise das wort
verhandlungen und perspektiven für
verhandlungen fällt hier in kiew relativ
selten bis gar nicht mehr zum jetzigen
stand im moment reden die ukraine hier
und allen voran auch präsident selensky
davon dass sanktionen erhöht werden
müssen dass waffenlieferungen verstärkt
werden müssen man redet auch von
reparationszahlungen mittlerweile für
eine mögliche nachkriegs perspektive
selensky hat ja gerade noch einmal
öffentlich auf die nachfrage nach
verhandlungen geäußert dass es für ihn
klar hier rote linien gäbe dass er sich
nicht damit abfinden würde dass russland
territorium der ukraine besetzen würde
er würde sich auch nicht auf einen
halbherzigen frieden zu kosten von land
gewinnen für russland einlassen also das
ist eine ziemlich klare haltung die die
ukraine hier vertritt und das ist
natürlich ganz entgegen den russischen
erwartungen dass sie hier möglicherweise
weiteres land annektieren könnten und
dass vielleicht sagen wir mal die
perspektive land für frieden eine option
wäre die für putin gesichtswahrend
diesen krieg beenden könnte da ist man
in kiew im moment relativ klar und hart
in der haltung dankeschön für diese
einschätzung live aus kiew katrin
eigendorf war das zdf heute live spricht
gleich mit einem mitarbeiter vom roten
kreuz der bei den evakuierungen aus
mario pohl dabei war um 19 uhr 30 in der
zdf- heute- app und auf unseren social
media kanälen
nach bayern für die csu ist es
ausgesprochen unangenehm ihr
generalsekretär stephan mayer musste
seinen hut nehmen weil er einen
journalisten übel beschimpft und bedroht
hat völlig unangemessen und indiskutabel
nannte das heute parteichef söder sprach
aber auch von einer menschlichen
tragödie aus münchen alexander pohl
der rücktritt seines generalsekretärs
und engsten mitarbeiters ist für markus
söder ein politischer gau stephan mayer
hatte einem redakteur der bunten nach
einem bericht über sein privatleben mit
vernichtung gedroht die dabei wohl
gefallen würde sind in keinster weise zu
akzeptieren
sind völlig unangemessen und auch an
indiskutabler stil in einem artikel
berichtet der reporter manfred
otzelberger von den
familienverhältnissen des csu
generalsekretärs für seinen unehelichen
sohn so heißt es zahlen nicht mehr
sondern dessen vater den unterhalt nach
der veröffentlichung rief mayer bei dem
reporter an er hat gepöbelt sofort
gedroht
dass er
hat die absurde these vertreten sie
haben mein leben zerstört
jetzt vernichte ich sie mit stefan maier
verliert csu-chef söder einen seiner
profiliertesten innenpolitiker die csu
wirkt im jahr vor der wahl verunsichert
in umfragen leicht verbessert aber eine
laut vernehmbare politische botschaft
fehlt die partei wird von ihrer
vergangenheit eingeholt gegen den
ehemaligen verkehrsminister steuer
ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft und ein
untersuchungsausschuss zur masken affäre
ist in vollem gang die csu ist wichtig
dass wir programmatisch
antworten geben vor allem auf die
landtagswahl die für uns die wichtigste
ist in eineinhalb jahren diese antworten
zu formulieren wäre auch die aufgabe des
neuen generalsekretärs den muss die csu
erst wieder finden bis freitag könnte
eine entscheidung fallen
die staatsanwaltschaft stuttgart hat
gegen baden-württembergs innenminister
strobel von der cdu ein
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet wegen
unerlaubter weitergabe von
gerichtsunterlagen im mittelpunkt steht
ein ranghoher polizist dem sexuelle
belästigung einer kollegin vorgeworfen
wird strobl hatte ein internes
rechtsanwalts schreiben in dieser sache
an einen journalisten weitergegeben
nordirland ist seit fast 100 jahren
gespalten zwischen denen die sich als
teil der republik irland fühlen und
denen die die zugehörigkeit zu
großbritannien verteidigen
morgen nun steht eine richtungswahl in
nordirland an es sind parlamentswahlen
und zum ersten mal könnten die irischen
nationalisten der stärkste kraft werden
über die möglichen folgen berichtet
yasin ihr nein es liegt historisches in
der luft bei diesen wahlen in nordirland
michelle o neals parteiisch in fällen
könnte die stärkste im parlament in
belfast werden und sie damit erste
ministerin erstmals legen dann die
katholischen republikaner vorn im land
die machtverhältnisse haben sich
verschoben unumkehrbar zu lasten wir das
wohl der bisher führenden demokratischen
unionisten gehen protestanten die sich
eine enge anbindung an großbritannien
wünschen eine wiedervereinigung irlands
wie schön sie fordert lehnen sie strikt
ab auch das so genannte nordirland
protokoll ist den unionisten ein dorn im
auge jene klausel die im brett abkommen
de facto eine zollgrenze zwischen
nordirland und dem rest des königreichs
schafft um die grenze zur republik
irland offen zu halten mauern zwischen
den katholischen und protestantischen
stadtteilen in belfast und kämpferische
wandmalereien zeigen die alten narben
des bürgerkriegs sind nicht gänzlich
verheilt die meisten jungen nordiren
haben damit nicht mehr viel am hut
die politik der vergangenheit die von
den politikern an der macht am leben
gehalten wird kümmert junge leute wenig
ähnlich nüchtern sehen dass nordirlands
unternehmer gerade hat man sich von den
folgen von corona erholt das letzte was
man jetzt gebrauchen kann ist neuerliche
ungewissheit in sachen drexhage es war
absolut kindisch den leuten zu erzählen
dass es keine handelsbarrieren geben
würde dass nordirland protokoll ist die
beste option nachdem vorher alle anderen
möglichkeiten ausgeschlossen wurden
deshalb wird es von den meisten
unternehmern auch befürwortet
der schlichte wunsch nach pragmatischen
lösungen wird gemäßigten kleineren
parteien diesmal viel zulauf bringen und
wird sich zeigen wo die reise hingeht
nach diesen wegweisenden wahlen in
nordirland
einige reiben sich schon voller
vorfreude die hände ab juni soll
hierzulande das neun euro ticket gelten
für insgesamt 27 euro kann man dann drei
monate lang unbegrenzt bus und
regionalbahnen nutzen es sind allerdings
noch einige hürden zu überwinden auch
die bundesländer müssen zustimmen und
die fordern mehr geld kai niklasch hat
details
das neun euro ticket soll impuls zur
verkehrswende und entlastung bei hohen
spritpreisen sein ab juni plant die
bundesregierung daher nahverkehr zum
schnäppchenpreis je neun euro für drei
monate wir wollen einen anreiz zum
energieeinsparen setzen und gleichzeitig
wollen wir auf den öpnv hinweisen und
menschen motivieren in stärker zu nutzen
das brauchen wir um energie zu sparen
unabhängig zu werden von energieimporten
und um unsere klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen
doch die länder sehen eine
unterfinanzierung von eineinhalb
milliarden euro bei der einführung des
tickets und fordern den bund auf diese
auszugleichen
wir erwarten dass der bund das
gegenfinanziert das können nicht die
kommunen das können nicht die pnv
unternehmen das können auch nicht die
länder alles gegenfinanzieren wenn der
bund so einen neuen euro ticket ins
leben ruft dann muss der bund auch dafür
zahlen außerdem muss noch geklärt werden
wie fahrgäste die bisher für abonnement
weit mehr als monatlich 9 euro zahlen
ihr geld zurückbekommen und weiteres
problem schon jetzt gibt es auf
beliebten strecken etwa von berlin an
die ostsee volle bahnsteige und züge
diesen trend könnte das ticket noch
verschärfen bei den regional express
erwarten haben wir jetzt schon der
starke aussagt und die gegen 100 prozent
geht und dann wird es dort sicherlich zu
überlastungen kommen die das system so
einfach nicht ran
noch wird das ticket nicht verkauft und
bis juni wird die zeit knapp denn noch
wollen bund länder und verkehrsbetriebe
daran festhalten
ökologisch gesehen lebt deutschland von
heute an auf pump umweltschützern
zufolge haben wir alle ressourcen
verbraucht die uns rein rechnerisch für
das ganze jahr zur verfügung stünden das
ist die botschaft des heutigen ehrt
überlastung starks die gründe für den
frühen termin sind unter anderem der
hohe energieverbrauch in deutschland der
hohe co2 ausstoß durch verkehr und
massentierhaltung sowie die
verunreinigung von böden luft und
grundwasser
und jetzt freuen wir uns mit jürgen
klopp seine lehrer stehen im champions
league durch den 3 2 sieg gestern abend
in villarreal klingt nach einer ziemlich
souverän sache was aber gar nicht die
spanier lange zeit auf augenhöhe führten
2 0 aber dann machten die reds doch noch
alles klar binnen zwölf minuten
emotionales ende des außenseiters aber
mit grandiosen komplimenten
respekt an villarreal stadion team und
coach unglaublich was die hier leisten
sie haben uns komplett unter druck
gesetzt villarreal hat das 0 2 aus dem
hinspiel nach 41 minuten auf im eigenen
hexenkessel aber waren zurück im spiegel
haben erst die tore unter das finale
doch noch wahr gemacht denn dann zeigt
lobte comeback mentalität seines teams
diaz eingewechselt das 2 zu 2 an allen
toren ist der kolumbianer beteiligt auch
am 3 zu 2 for money als revanche für die
finalniederlage 2018 wünschen sich die
reds nun real madrid
an ihrem spiel gestern abend das könnte
sich heute abend wiederholen wenn
nämlich manchester city bei real madrid
antritt das dramatische hinspiel das
gewann ja die mannschaft von pep
guardiola knapp mit drei zu vier ein
englisches finale also durchaus möglich
aber der trainer der königlichen carlo
ancelotti der hat angekündigt wir werden
das ding heute abend wenn vor 60.000
zuschauern im bernabeu-stadion
ja und die zusammenfassung der beiden
halbfinal rückspiele mit ausführlichen
analysen und gesprächen heute abend bei
uns im sportstudio champions league um
23 uhr 15 zur basketball-euroleague da
hat bayern münchen das entscheidende
fünfte viertelfinal spiel gegen
barcelona mit 2 1 872 zu 81 verloren und
hat den einzug in die best of four
verpasst und in der handball european
league da gab es gestern abend einen
heimsieg des sc magdeburg der bundesliga
tabellenführer gewann das
viertelfinal-rückspiel gegen nord knapp
aber durchaus verdient mit 30 zu 28 und
zieht damit ins finale der besten vier
ein überragender magdeburger michael
tango mit zwölf treffern
das finalturnier dann am letzten
maiwochenende magdeburg ist ja auch der
titelverteidiger und jetzt fehlt noch
lottozahlen sie lauten 3 4 11 31 41 49
superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157
in der nacht klingen schauer und
gewitter ab kommen aber morgen wieder
nur nicht im nord und
nordwestdeutschland details hat gleich
katja honnefer christian sievers begrüßt
sie um viertel vor zehn im heute-journal
und hier übernimmt morgen mitri sirin
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen
und bis bald auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
auch heute gab es wieder tages gang
wetter also regenschauer und gewitter
die sich im laufe des tages mehr und
mehr ausbreiteten wie zum beispiel in
baden-württemberg und in bayern auch im
saarland in rheinland-pfalz später dann
auch richtung thüringen und sachsen im
nordwesten bekam sie von regenschauern
und gewittern eigentlich gar nichts ab
und das bleibt jetzt auch in der nacht
so schauer und gewitter erreichen aber
bis zum frühen morgen hier berlin und
morgen ziehen schauer und gewitter
ostwärts und südostwärts ab am
nachmittag kann es dann hier am rhein
wieder einige schauer geben heute nacht
bleibt ist also zum teil auch mal
trocken zwischen der ostseeküste und der
mosel und die temperaturen sinken auf
zehn grad am oberrhein und in der
uckermark in norddeutschland und auch am
alpenrand gibt es auf 3 bis 1 grad
runter da droht also noch einmal
bodenfrost die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen an der küste und bei dauerregen
im südwesten muss aber 13 bis 16 grad
sonst werden 15 bis 21 grad erreicht und
auch morgen gibt es wieder schauer und
gewitter in norddeutschland bleibt es
dagegen trocken und am nachmittag kann
es vom rhein her einige schauer geben
bei nordwest wird in den nächsten tagen
wird der samstag der durchwachsenen tag
werden und die temperaturen ändern sich
kaum
guten abend